- [Gary] Some other, like, you
know, if they work for a leader
like you, you know
what's gonna happen.
If they go into another agency
they may not like it so...
(triumphant rock music)
What if I told you
this is the last
Monday morning of your life?
- Plain bagels
and cream cheese,
eggs ones toasted,
plain is not.
Plates and napkins.
- This is literally why
we're gonna go out of business.
(group laughter)
This is a complete
waste of money.
Really excited
together this morning.
Just trying to a lot more
face time with small groups.
Just get to jam with different
peeps and things of that nature
so just wanted to jam.
See how you guys were doing.
See what's going on.
See if we could shoot
the shit a little bit.
Talk about stuff.
I think worst decisions I make
is when my word got in the way.
So one thing I've been thinking
a lot about is the decisions
I don't make that
I'm pumped with is
because I'm not willing
to go back on my word
and that is really easy
for me do it as VaynerMedia.
Like as I always say, the only
thing constant is change so it's
easy to say like, "Hey,
we're eliminating project,"
I'm almost secretly want to
bring project management
back just to do it.
Just to remind everybody
why I believe in that.
So as a company
and as a business
I think it's my
biggest strength.
As a guy, it's the
biggest, it's the reverse.
It's like the thing that matters
to me most is not to go back on
my word and the problem is a lot
of times the other human being
doesn't hold up their end of the
bargain but they don't see it.
I feel great.
I feel like we're so
hungry to be great that
we're hypersensitive
to things that are...
We make things that are
C issues A+ issues
because we just are winners.
I have a good idea.
A video series that is the
perfect wine if you're
21 to 30 years old to start
getting into wine with and
then we target 21 to
30-year-olds in New Jersey.
You know, the perfect wine to
give to your boss if you work at
and then let's find the top
three New Jersey employers.
Just like as a joke,
things like that
targeting people in New Jersey
and it says free shipping
and it's a video. It will work.
About to go into
personal finance meeting.
We will not be filming.
- [DRock] L.A.
and Chicago.
- [Tyler] Chicago first.
- [DRock] Chicago
for a day, at 3:50.
Yes?
- [Gary] Well now that
I have a camera, you know,
I'm settling the score.
Go ahead.
- [Woman] Can you not
shoot while you're driving?
- I wasn't.
- [Woman] It was Saturday.
- No, I wasn't shooting.
Justin was shooting.
- [Woman] Even
talking to camera.
I was a little
nervous about you.
- People talk to other people
sitting in the
passenger seat driving.
- [Woman 2] Hey Gary!
- Hey guys! How are you?
- [Man] Good to see you.
Heading up to meet
you guys right now.
- [Gary] Are you?
Good to see you, man.
You well?
- [Man] How are you doing?
- [Gary] Good.
This is the owner of the
Miami Dolphins which is
a bad thing but a much better
thing is this is Stephen Ross.
My only non-family member
business partner in my life.
Somebody that I look up
to and everybody should.
Steve, say something nice.
- It's great being partners
with Gary Vaynerchuk,
I got to tell you.
- (laughs) I love it.
- It's a trip. (laughs)
- We're having a great lunch.
He just said something
that motivated me.
He's like, "I just
have all these ideas."
When you have this kind of fire
whether your two or 76 or 176,
nothing beats the
entrepreneurial fire.
I love it.
Steve, five wins in a
row for the Dolphins.
- Six.
- [Woman 3] Hey Gary.
- [Gary] Hey, how are you?
- [Woman 3] Good, how are you?
- [Michael] How you doing?
- [Gary] Good to see you, man.
How you been?
- [Michael] Nice to see you.
It's been a long time.
- [Gary] Yeah, it's
been a long time.
Great to see you.
I would love for this to be,
tell me straight up,
how can I help?
Like tell me what's
important to you?
What are you thinking about?
You may not know how I can
help but tell me the 4-1-1.
When you think about this city
there is an absolute and based,
I can already tell your taste,
just probably thinking
about John and other things and
then just think about
wineries, right?
There is an absolute,
here's what you need,
you need me to
be boxed out of it.
If I wasn't me and had wine
relationships and didn't hear
this conversation but
I was me as a human being,--
- [Michael] Yeah.
- I need to be box
out of the first one.
It needs to be expensive
and I needed to miss it.
And then you have something.
- [Michael] To
create some demand--
- 100%, it's never
about year one anyway.
This is where
everybody fucks up.
It's never about year one.
- [Michael] That part,
I agree.
- [Gary] I know you do.
You know this.
I mean I know it
but you know it.
You know it better than me in
reality, I know it in theory.
So that's why I'm going
with the, is it actually 1500?
Is it actually expensive?
- [Michael] Yeah.
- Is it actually, fucking, you
know, three, four, five, seven,
I don't know, thousand but
is it fucking ridiculous?
Is it...
Snoop Dogg and some country star
that's huge right now
are gonna perform--
- [Michael] Miranda Lambert.
- Great, Miranda Lambert while
you eat
Shake Shack burgers
with '61 Lafite.
Like a double mashup
You see where I'm going?
- [Michael] Burgers and
Bordeaux is a great pairing.
- Right. So, you see
where I'm going?
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- You can win that game.
- [Michael] It's the ultimate--
- You can win, you need
basically, listen,
this city's super simple.
Every guy here wants to think
that the biggest (censored) and
if you can trick them
into that game, you've won.
And you reverse engineer that.
- [Michael] I wish I had that.
I know I don't have
the biggest (censored).
- I'm definitely not
even in the run,
I'm not even in the running.
- That's unfortunate.
(laughter)
Yeah. Hey, it's good to see you.
- Real pleasure.
We'll, like I said, the biggest
is, now we're just in flow.
- [Michael] Yeah.
That's cool.
- [Gary] Alright.
Real pleasure.
Rainy day in New York City,
bunch of good meetings today.
Great meeting
with Steve Ross,
you guys saw that clip.
Go ahead, don't be scared.
Don't be scared.
- I'm always eating
when the camera's on.
Just a good buzz in the office,
actually do some B-roll,
DRock, right now.
Good buzz, everybody's
rocking and rolling.
Just a classic fucking Tuesday
in November doing our shit.
("Entertain You" by JKMK)
It was funny, it's so weird,
I wasn't even thinking
about us later in the day.
I said to her, "Do you know
how many fucking hipsters
"would wear
(censored) on T-shirts?"
That was
literally in the meeting.
The answer of, "Hey, the brand
lift in itself through this
"execution is worth it plus
you're gonna make one third or
"two thirds economics on
whatever is built and here's a
"guy who's done it and he's done
it for Madonna and we're gonna
"do it for (censored), we're
gonna do it for (censored)."
The answer's yes.
- [Man 3] They're
all not incentivized.
- [Gary] Correct.
- [Man 3] To accept our message.
- So are you trying
to message to them?
- [Man 3] Yes.
- Let me give you a
really good piece of advice.
- [Man 3] Okay.
- Never sell to the unsellable.
- [Man 3] Yep.
- What? You think you're
gonna be charming enough?
I think the question becomes
the fact that you don't have the
option to completely framework
the going around or different
things in the fact that
you're stuck and you,
great that's very nice,
Gary but that's
actually what
I have to do for living.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- The question is you
can't sell to them in
any normal way whatsoever.
- [Man 3] Our job is to try to
figure how message to them and
convince them
without selling to them.
That's the whole point.
- The question is who though.
'Cause if you're selling to your
contemporaries and they're being
blocked above them because
it's not in the profit margin
interest of the organization,
that's like selling to these
four characters when
I'm gonna stop them.
("Everything" by Kaiolyn)
- [Gary] Not that.
Okay.
I would see him in L.A.
for a little bit though.
- [Tyler] 6:40 you're in
and out in 35, 40 minutes
and come back. Cool?
- [Gary] Cool. See ya.
Hey.
There's some good content today.
Think it could become an
extremely meaningful revenue
center and a place where I can
put the future leaders of my
organization to get closer to me
and to learn more
autonomy and to...
I just, the truth is a lot
more than you would think.
The three of us, the six of us
whatever it is are going to sell
something for $200,000 that
we used to give away for free.
I just I'm excited
about that. (laughs)
That's a good idea in business.
I'm really well.
I love your Instagram post.
Yes.
So, listen, I want to
have this over a dinner.
You're a important
cog in my machine.
We had our most meaningful chat
five minutes into
your tenure at a picnic.
I'd like to set up one about one
and a half hour drinks or dinner
in January, mid-January
to have this conversation.
The answer is we're gonna do
both and I want to really talk
about you and us and me and life
and so I don't want to make this
a 10 minute conversation.
I think punting this to
six weeks from today,
giving the preview that the
answer's gonna be both but
more importantly taking it to a
macro level and like really
getting aligned on the
short-term and
long-term futures.
I am very excited
about you, man.
I want to really
start building our bond.
That's a priority for me
and '17 and this seems
like a great starting off point.
Yeah, and it will just, it's
also the lend itself to bigger
macro conversations that
I think could be really fun
and inspiring on both ends.
Okay. So just set something
up with Tyler right now.
Alright? How you doing
otherwise, all good?
Love it, alright,
cool, sounds good.
I'll see you soon.
Alright, bye-bye.
- [Sam] Music intro, little
intro, I set you up.
- [Gary] Benrubi,
do a little Instagram and
Snapchat Stories for me.
- [Sam] I set you up
with just a little history.
Ready?
- Yeah.
- [Sam] You ever do this before?
- Once or twice.
Keep a quite close communication
with Brandon and my dad and know
a lot about what's
going on in the industry.
I think one of the things that's
really fascinating to me is much
like I was very right about
Burgundy's explosion
a decade ago, I'm positive--
- [Sam] What preceded that?
Bordeauxs?
- Yes, and cult California cabs.
- [Sam] It shifted to Burgundy.
- Yeah.
- [Sam] Not
because of the Chinese.
- [Gary] A little bit for a few
minutes but just by logic.
- [Sam] Right.
- Once Parker became
not the only voice in wine,
people started
saying things like--
- We'll get to him
in a few seconds.
- Okay, I'm always
trying to set you up.
What happened was
as Parker became one
of the most important
voices instead the only voice
like he was for 15 years,
along with Wine Spectator,
what happened was people started
deploying logic and they said,
you know, there's 28,000 cases
being made of
Château Lebron or Lafite
and there's 330 of this
single vineyard Burgundy and so
just supply and
demand kicked in.
- [Sam] So that
allure of collecting--
- Don't forget Parker got
kicked out of Burgundy.
There was a lot of
controversy there.
- [Sam] He was the Cali
cab and Bordeaux head--
- And Rhone but he loved
Burgundy but the truth is
I won't speak to it
because I don't even fully,
I never fully knew the story.
I could recall it.
He had a controversy
with a couple producers.
He stopped reviewing Burgundy.
That's why brought on
Piore Rowanie way back when he
first introduced another critic
and so what happened was
Burgundy just wasn't that
important to the
high net worth individuals
of America and then
they became it and then
supply and demand kicked in.
I believe the same thing
will happen to Barolo.
So my big prediction here
on Heritage Radio Network--
- [Sam] On the Grape Nation--
- on the Grape Nation--
- [Sam] where we're
bringing wine to the people.
- we're bringing
wine to the people--
- [Sam] So the trend is?
- the trend is if you're a
collector and you want to buy
some wine for your kids weddings
or like the guy who
hosts this show's
made some good money
on flipping some wine,
he made some good bets,
I would buy
small tiny production
highly rated,
sought after Borolo.
Bruno Giacosa, red label.
- [Sam] Conterno.
- Conterno, single vineyards
because I believe that
Borolo will become
a dominant wine
of choice of the
next generation 'cause
it sits in between that
Pinot Noir-Cabernet cycle--
- [Sam] It has the
finesse and the complexities.
- Uh-huh but the power.
Rick who just made his first big
check at Goldman Sachs at 28,
he's gonna buy at the restaurant
try to impress the girl that
he's trying to hook
up with that night--
- [Sam] Good Borolo?
- A tig, a Sassicaia, a Celeya.
He's not gonna say, "Hey baby,
check out this Aldo Conterno."
- [Sam] Right.
To me, that's where
the opportunity lies.
- [Sam] I think
you're right on that.
- By the way, Rick's girlfriend
in that scenario is Sally.
- [Sam] Looking at and drinking.
- So this is such iconic wine.
First of all,
thanks for sharing it.
You know the color's
black, dark, unbelievably--
- [Sam] 13 year old wine.
- which is incredible 'cause
it usually loses some
of that intensity.
- [Sam] There's
rust on the edge.
- On the nose, it's got
hard-core black jam a little
hint of--
- [Sam] Heavy black.
- really black, by the way.
Like super juicy feels like
you're smelling red fruit,
blueberries, blackberries, black
fruit as well for that reason.
A little hint of tobacco
on the nose on the tail end
you get a little smoke.
- [Sam] I get a little
graphite, charcoal smoke.
- Yep, 100% whether it's a
match or little bit tobacco,
it depends on your nose,
that's what you'll get.
On the palate--
- [Sam] Mouthfeel?
- [Gary] So this
is interesting, right?
I do know for DRock, you and Ben,
you know, depending on where
your wine palates are, you can
feel a little bit of tannins on
the backend but they're so soft.
- [Sam] They are very soft.
- And usually it's bitter.
- [Sam] Tell people
what the tannins are.
- That puckery, tough flavor
you taste when
he taste red wine.
- [Sam] The puckery flavor from
the skins, the seeds, the stems.
- Yeah, all the stuff
that isn't the fruit.
As you can imagine, by the
way, very easy even if you're
underage to learn this.
Go take a grape,
eat the skin versus
eating the actual grape.
That transcends into red wine.
It gets bitter if you remember
the old bitter beer face
commercials, which I thought was
really funny by the way, anyway
nonetheless what's great about
this is this is what
aged wine's all about.
This wine eight, nine, 10 years
ago would've felt hot on the
back end 'cause the alcohol--
- [Sam] It's calmed
down a little?
- Of course, so
this is an elegance.
You know what this is?
This is like a 42-year-old
distinguished gentleman
who's got a little gray
coming in, right?
- [Sam] Still handsome--
- Was an absolute like
boy band rockstar
handsome at 19, heartthrob.
- [Sam] Justin Timberlake.
- Timberlake
would be great comp.
42-year-old Justin Timberlake is
what this wine is
and so I like that.
It's balanced, long finish.
I'm still tasting it and
much like 42-year-old
Justin Timberlake,
and he's happily married
so I don't wanna wish
this on him, but still
has plenty of game. Right?
This wine can probably
last another 15 years easily.
- [Sam] In the bottle.
- Having the
fruit of the bottle.
It's really good.
- [Sam] Benrubi and you've been
listening to the Grape Nation.
We'll see you next time.
That was great.
- [Gary] I love you, pal.
- [Sam] Were you good with that?
- [Gary] I was great with that.
I'm glad we had that on tape.
- [Sam] Fun show.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Sam] Thanks for coming in.
- [Gary] Talk to you soon.
DRock, we got to go. See ya!
That was fun.
Send me a link when it's live.
- [Sam] I'll send
you everything.
- Hey, thanks.
Nice job.
- [Gary] Real pleasure.
Thank you, brother.
("Jellyfish" by Jenny Renolds)
- 12:03 in the morning,
leaving the office.
Like we do.
Good hustle, Tyler.
Good night.
Good day.
Big VaynerSports
meeting just now.
Gonna fucking change the game.
Whoops, gonna
change the fucking game.
Just like Wine Library,
just like VaynerMedia,
VaynerSports is
gonna change the game.
Pay attention.
(clicks tongue)